le favori jo byden 77 ans 8 ans auprès
de barack obama à la maison blanche ont
assuré une solide crédibilité à l'ancien
vice président des états unis depuis son
entrée en lice en avril il se maintient
en tête des sondages mais c'est
traditionnel gaffe préoccupe
si je suis le candidat je le battrai
comme un tambour
s'il ne fait pas de bons scores dans
l'iowa et le new hampshire les deux
premiers états à voter il perdra son
statut de favori deuxième grande figure
démocrate le sénateur bernie sanders 78
premier dans les sondages de l'iowa
grâce à des levées de fonds record à
grand soutien des jeunes et malgré une
crise cardiaque à l'automne 2010 9 celui
qui appelle à une révolution politique
pour une société plus juste et ferait
une partie de l'électorat démocrate
premières figures féminines la sénatrice
elizabeth warren 77 ans est classée
troisième dans les sondages nationaux
après avoir été jusqu'à menacer le
favori jo byden dans les intentions de
vote cet ancien républicaine
pourfendeuse de wall street a perdu la
faveur des électeurs pour avoir trop
tergiverser sur la question de la
réforme de la santé est essentielle aux
états unis première surprise de cette
campagne petite boutique gay gay 38 ans
homosexuel fervent croyant diplômés de
prestigieuses universités mais sans
expérience au niveau national et son
soutien dans le parti ce maire d'une
petite ville du midwest a aussi servi en
afghanistan
chaque fois que mon parti a gagné la
maison blanche au cours des 50 dernières
années c'est avec le candidat qui était
nouveau dans la politique nationale
concentrer sur l'avenir
pas pris dans les voix de washington et
ouvrant la porte à une nouvelle
génération de leadership
voilà comment nous gagnons cinquième
dans les sondages nationaux il est
troisième dans l'iowa
s'il était élu il deviendrait le plus
jeune président de l'histoire des états
unis
seconde femme amy klobuchar 59 ans est
sénatrice du minnesota petite fille d'un
mineur est avec elizabeth warren l'autre
favorite assumé du puissant quotidien
new york times en cinquième position
dans l'iowa
elle ne parvient pas à séduire
sur le plan national le seul candidat
d'origine asiatique encore inconnu il y
a un an l'homme d'affaires andrew yang
45 ans s'est fait connaître avec une
proposition un revenu universel mensuel
de 1000 $ pour tous les américains
enfin michael bloomberg 77 ans quatrième
dans les sondages au niveau national est
bien connu du public ce milliardaire
ancien maire de new york
ex républicain puis indépendants se
démarque avec une stratégie inédite
faire l'impasse sur les votes des quatre
premiers états il ne se présente qu'à
partir du super tuesday le 3 mars
lorsqu'une quinzaine d'états votre ou
[Musique]